welcome back to the 51st ever episode
of the iced coffee hour i'm meet kevin
and so far the show has made fifty six
thousand seven hundred and sixty dollars
welcome aboard
wow that was so good yeah you're a pro
at this man
so for those not aware meet kevin has a
fantastic youtube channel where
you basically stream 24 7 you post like
six videos every single day about the
stock market the real estate market
what's going on
with uh stimulus plan it's it's a bit of
everything when it comes to finances
and you've grown a lot over this last
year you've tripled your channel haven't
you
it's been insane i think i went into
2020 with like 290
000 subs so whatever that is it's been
nuts
wow great work man
you put us all to shame with how many
videos you're posting you basically do
in a day
what uh what we do in a week throughout
four channels in a week yeah
oh no stop well i love your guys variety
i'm jealous about your guy's variety i
feel like i'm stuck in this chair
you guys got the the show you got the
vlog
i'm jealous man the reactions i love it
why don't you do a vlog uh well first of
all we're not doing anything
you know we're still we're still kind of
we feel cloistered at home and it's
really
boring we can't wait to get out again we
want stuff to open
i need to get out of here i'm going to
lose my mind i'm going to start throwing
things
but you would be able to set up a vlog
now so that like let's say in a month
you would be starting to do things you
can like just set up like a blog channel
or or just set up
kevin yeah no set up a channel hire
somebody to just vlog for you they do
all the filming they do all the editing
so that by the time you actually go and
do stuff you're in the process of buying
a house right now right
vlog that's true try it and get one
under contract
yes and you're and you're trying to have
a another child right i mean maybe don't
vlog
all of that or do it's elective
right so if you could vlog really easily
and you had someone else take care of
everything
would you consider doing it yeah i think
that that'd be a consideration if i was
doing stuff like uh you know we
we i'm hoping by the summer things open
up and i'm totally gamed like if i could
just do my morning
our morning market live stream and then
do the closing live stream
i got like another six hours of the day
let's go let's go to the beach you know
be at the beach at like 1 30 1 45
whatever do whatever i think it'd be fun
yeah sure
i think that would do so well like meet
kevin's family
something like that the stam
mustang you got to have it like yours
jeez but you know what else you could
vlog you were telling us right before we
went into this about a 12
million dollar yolo bet what's
what's this about yeah so basically
what i did is i i paid off all my margin
which was something that was kind of
just like
i don't know i'd look at it i'm like how
why do i have six million dollars in
margin like if the market went went to
the toilet
uh i can't come up with six million
dollars at the snap of a finger and pay
that off
so i'm like this is not so good uh and
and i i
really believe that any kind of
short-term thing would just be
short-term but when you've got margin
man
these banks they got you you know they
got you in such a position where they
can really uh you know sell everything
you got
to pay off that debt and sell you at
bottom we saw that with gamestop too
when gamestop the first time around
started crashing robin hood just starts
liquidating people yeah
so at bottom prices too so i uh i
decided to
uh sell it was uh nine and a half
million dollars of stocks is what i
sold uh and i bought
uh back 3.9 million dollars in
options uh various different expirations
uh and somebody did this calculation for
me
i did a rough calculation they did the
exact calculation for me
and the exact number is if i were to
want to have the same
upside with shares as i have with that
3.9 in options i would have to have
12 million 176
thousand dollars in shares so i'm
basically controlling that much
potential market value
with just 3.7 million and since i sold
like nine
i got rid of my six million in margin
and i'm actually
controlling more exposure to the market
now isn't there a chance those options
expire worthless
there's a chance so there's a chance so
so your downside
is going to be three something million
dollars if you exactly
lose this right so my my the way i was
looking at this was that
if uh uh if there's like a margin call
you know if the market goes to crap
i mean the odds are the market wouldn't
go to crap i think it'd be pretty low to
get margin called i've never been margin
called it'd have to be some
crazy crisis but uh the worst case
scenario on having the margin
is they uh they liquidate your shares
at such a low level that you've now the
market's crashed to such a level where
they sell you out at bottom
they eliminate your margin they take
away your credit line so you can't even
buy again at bottom if you wanted to
because you'd had nothing
you'd probably be throwing in cash to
try to prevent the margin calls so you
wouldn't have any cash
and you'd kind of lose half your
portfolio
quickly through uh through a really bad
what could just be a flash crash who
knows
maybe some crazy thing happens in in
june and uh you know
the s p 500 and the dow is down 40 who
knows right
whatever the new covet strain or
whatever and so i thought that
okay there's a big risk that gosh what
if like you know
potentially uh you know six to seven to
ten million dollars of your portfolio
just get eradicated
and i thought okay well here now i'm
only taking a 3.9 3.8 ish million dollar
risk
and i don't believe that's going to go
to zero it could go to zero if i held
them all
but i can always trade for longer term
options out in the future so even if
there were
you know setbacks in the market i could
always grab like a 2024 option next year
so since some of these are 2023s i'm
optimistic
that uh i'm gonna be okay but the whole
rationale behind it is
i think we're going i think things are
gonna be great i really think things are
going to get better so i've actually
taken this
i'm calling it a yolo because i'm taking
much more risk because yeah
you know the options fluctuate way more
it could be a really stupid mistake if
the markets
trade sideways or downwards for the next
two years but i don't see it
i think we're going up and i'm pretty
confident of that
why not just go and buy the shares you'd
be sitting pretty comfy just like four
million bucks
invested and then you would never have
to worry about it
yeah i don't know i i i don't you know
about
well uh i could have done that and uh
i think i think that's where it becomes
a little yellowy because i could have
easily done that right we could have
sold
uh well i just wouldn't have had had to
sell as much uh i could have uh what i
did is i closed out my m1 finance
and so i closed down my m1 finance to
concentrate into my higher conviction
holdings
so i i had all these uh funds available
and i found okay what do i want to do
with this i've got you know 3.9 million
dollars here
do i go shopping for options do i go
shopping for shares the beautiful thing
about shares is you never have to pay
taxes if you don't want to you could
just hold them forever right
and this was right before the whole joe
biden capital gains thing yeah we'll
talk about that in a second
yeah oh yeah we got to talk about that
but yeah i mean
at the time i was thinking oh no problem
we'll be able to
uh you know we'll hold these options for
long-term capital gains i'll have no
margin
and i think i think this the way i
convinced myself
to try to eliminate the margin
is that okay well if i do options i
could have
uh no margin but potentially have
a really big upside to where i end up
way better off
than where i was before like that 12
million dollars imagine that
that or these options the option values
if we get a big rally this summer or
this fall
that could triple or quadruple in value
and so i look at that i go sweet i
believe
there's a chance that some of these
things are going to do that maybe not
all of the ones that i chose
but i believe there's a chance that
maybe tesla will maybe uh
you know all tesla has to do is double
in the options about quadruple in value
triple to quadruple in value
so i figure you know what let's let's do
a little bit of a yolo it's 27
of my portfolio i really believe the
market's gonna rally either this fall
winter or beginning of next year let me
put my money where my mouth is
and if it works out i'll be able to look
back and go
dang i got rid of margin didn't miss a
beat in the market
uh and made more money it's it's just a
bet
you know why what i mean i think it's
super smart
and but only really obviously i'm sure
you have but assessed your risk
tolerance
which i'm sure you have you said it was
27 of your portfolio
i think it's super smart i've actually
recently been buying some leap calls
which i've never really done before but
just i want to say in the past like
month or two i bought like a couple uh
long calls on uh on palantir
because they were so dirt cheap like far
in the money too
and so far i'm up so yeah what makes you
think
what makes you so confident the market's
going to go up
well so a few things um one i think
we have uh in my opinion i think there's
an overvaluation right now
in recovery stocks like restaurants
airlines
travel i think they've had this insane
run since november
and i think they're really overvalued
for what are gonna be crappy earnings
they're not gonna be good
uh you know sure they didn't go bankrupt
so the bankruptcy risk is gone
and that totally makes sense like great
the companies go back like simon
property group's not a bankruptcy risk
anymore
so fine it's selling for 116 a share
instead of 49
a share like it was in the summer when
people were thinking that's it it's over
moles are going bankrupt and we thought
it might be years to get a vaccine right
so the run that we've seen makes sense
but do we really think
simon property group it used to trade
for 150
before the pandemic do we really think
this is going to go from 116 to 200
anytime soon
i don't i wouldn't make that bet what do
i think is going to happen first tech
doubling
or that doubling you know i i'll stick
with the tech
and over the last few couple months here
we've had a big old sell-off in tech
and growth because of inflation fears
i don't believe the inflation is coming
so in part
my bet is that we're going to have this
period of inflation
but that long-term inflation that people
are fearful of i don't think is gonna be
here
and so i thought well how can i make a
bet that
if if my script and i realize that's
that's
dangerous is having a script but if i
have a script of what the market does
is it's garbage for the next you know
what we've seen already the last two
months garbage through the summer
totally possible
maybe sideways trading whatever we get
all this uncertainty and doubt and fear
garbage until we start seeing inflation
trend downwards
inflation starts trending downwards
september october
and all of a sudden markets look and go
oh my gosh
we just printed all of that money and
yeah a bunch of other countries around
the world did but we're the first to
recover
we have more growth in our country than
we did before
in 2019 and our trajectory's gone up
which is crazy because
the way i think about it is like we were
on this trajectory he'd have
hit this hole of the pandemic now we're
not
back to that same line we're actually
higher
than that same line because of all the
stimulus that's been happening the
amount of growth that's coming to this
country is is going to be insane
statistically that's what we're seeing
so far
the only thing that could stop it would
be if inflation runs rampant
i don't believe it will because
historically it hasn't the last uh
you know 20 30 years we've been on a
downtrend 40 years we've been on a
downtrend on inflation
i think that's going to continue i side
with the fed on this
and so i say look i believe i'm 70
plus likely to be right in my bet and uh
it'll work out well
i think there's a 10 chance the market
trades down
and i lose all those options and i think
it's less than 10
the fact that they would go to zero i
think is low because i would probably
trade into longer terms
like in 2022 i just trade up for longer
terms 2024s or whatever
uh and then i think there's this 20
chance and this
stupid ear things bugging me but i think
there's a 20 chance the market trades
sideways
which uh which would be bad as well
but so i look at it i go hey look if i
can play roulette
and somebody tells me i got a 70 chance
of winning 70 plus percent chance of
winning
and uh 20 chance that you're kind of
break even-ish
i thought you know at the same time as
me being able to get out of margin while
still having more exposure to the market
i'm like sign me up worst case scenario
if i lose that 3.7
not gonna make a difference in my life
what are you seeing kind of crappy
right now in the market because you say
things you know aren't looking so good
right now they're gonna be kind of
crappy between now and through summer
the only things that i'm really seeing
crappy right now are spacks
a lot of cause because a lot of tech is
still relatively high when you look back
from even six months ago
we're still better we might not be as
high as we were in january february but
we're still doing pretty good
yep yep yeah uh and this is true
whoa where are we graham i don't know
man but i'm just on public right now
public but we're in private no public
the free stock trading app
what tell me more yeah it's a free stock
trading app where you could buy and sell
stocks for as little as a dollar
and best of all they don't route your
order flow oh my god that sounds amazing
yeah but not only that there's a social
media feature
where you could see what your friends
are buying and you could read up on
stock information wow it seems just like
twitter but all about investing
yeah and best of all if you sign up
using the link down below in the
description they'll give you a free
stock worth all the way up to fifty
dollars
how much up to fifty dollars
wow is there anything else i should know
yeah when you deposit a hundred dollars
on the platform by may 7th
you'll be entered for a chance to win a
completely free stock of tesla
wow i'm gonna do that right now should
our audience do this too
absolutely you too could get a free
stock worth all the way up to fifty
dollars and plus you could follow me in
public and see exactly what i'm
investing in awesome thank you so much
for doing it right now i look forward to
seeing you on there and now we should
get back to the video
so um there are a few things going on
and
uh it's it's uh dolly
so i guess the place that i believe to
start
is i think people have first of all a
lot of fear that we are having this
this this massive inflation is coming
and it's here to stay in fact i would
venture to say that probably
80 to 90 percent of people who are gonna
be commenting on this video i'm going to
say kevin's crazy like inflation is here
to stay i get it i think i'm making a
contrarian bet here
i think i'm not siding with the majority
of people i think i'm siding with the
minority people
who who actually don't think inflation
will last and that's because
inflation feels so real right now
because we're seeing prices of
everything go up around us
uh and there there are no shortages of
anecdotes
uh there might be supply shortages but
there are no shortages of anecdotes of
people saying
oh this is more expensive this more
expensive of course
pandemics screwed up a lot of things but
i think we're going to go back
to lower levels of inflation because i
believe so much in our global supply
chains
that companies are competitive they
don't want to raise prices
they want to beat their competitors they
want to have more market share
and they want to do so more efficiently
which they can also thank you because
the pandemic
because so many people are working at
home now you just cut out business
travel one sales person can
talk to 50 people in a day where what
used to be you know one
medical sales rep going to maybe three
doctor's offices in a day now they're
going to 20 or more
you see what i mean it's to me we are we
are seeing
so many deflationary polls in in other
words
companies being able to have more profit
margins just simply because of
how how common it is now to telecommute
you think you do a sales presentation on
zoom before the pandemic
no freaking way now yeah where how else
would we do it you know what i mean
so i'm yeah i'm wondering with your
sales rep
uh analogy there i'm wondering let's
just say
doctors are now inundated with just zoom
call zoom call zoom call
don't you think then that the tables are
gonna turn and now now you're gonna
think like well
i'm gonna be the only one who's gonna
show up in person and then all of a
sudden that one in person
person is going to stand out above the
rest because they made the effort to
show up
i'm here here's what i have to offer and
i feel like it's it's easier to say no
to somebody
over a call i think when you're in
person sometimes you have that
energy that it's like you you want to do
business with that person because you
see them face to face
i don't know if that's going away
anytime soon look there's
no nothing's ever gonna i think in the
long term replace the handshake deal
right getting in the boardroom and
making a deal
i think though and this is just the the
excitement that i have about
where our market is heading i think
every company
is looking at it maybe maybe not just
sales but it's every layer of the
company
from human resources to gosh i'm sure
internal i.t support everything going a
virtual now
uh everything is so much more
streamlined and these are all all these
numbers are going to show up in bottom
line margins especially for these tech
companies
so there's that big shift that's
massively deflationary
uh and and so i think i'm gonna be right
about inflation i think we're gonna have
low inflation you might be right yeah i
mean the handshake deals at some point
they will come back uh but then again
you might have doctors who are like look
you know for me to sit down in a meeting
with you i could be meeting with 10
clients
like this isn't worth my time who knows
we'll see what happens but that's a good
counter
uh but it's not just the inflation
argument you've also got
a lot of hedge funds right now shorting
the market
uh and partially de-leveraging a lot of
de-leveraging started happening after
the archaegos fallout
which when people spend if people take
on less debt or companies take on less
debt
they they put less buying pressure on
the market so you see stocks have well
less buying pressure
uh then you're seeing hedge funds short
because they're like there's no way
these tech companies are hitting these
earnings
because the earnings expectations are
through the roof so hedgies are shorting
if they're right they have their long
positions if they're wrong they don't
lose their clients because they have
their short positions
but that also puts downside pressure on
stocks
i think all of that is is uh weighing on
the market so you have inflation fear
you have de-leveraging you have uh hedge
funds shorting
you have the spec attack you've got
biden doing
crazy stuff with okay are we gonna print
2.2 trillion dollars or are we going to
print
4 trillion dollars what's it going to be
biden you say you're negotiable we don't
know we got the corporate tax thing now
we got the capital gains thing that just
came out this week there's so much where
people are like
dude i don't even know what to make of
all of this
is the fed gonna taper soon everybody's
like
chicken with head cut off and that's
when i want to double down in the market
you said that you think there may be a
10 chance
that the inflation happens or whatever
if i if i remember correctly
what do you think that 10 chance looks
like and what would hap like
what would have to happen to cause that
that 10
chance yeah so 10 chance of me losing
all
like like having a having a bear market
by the time my ex uh my options expire
which which would i think relate to
being wrong about inflation
so i think in september
uh october by then we'll know we'll see
inflation numbers are going to come in
very high over the next two months the
highest we've ever seen uh you know here
are may reading for april june reading
for may
they're going to be a disaster the
headline numbers are going to be 3.5
3.6 percent it's going to be the ugliest
numbers we've seen forever
or at least in uh in the last you know
15 20 years i think the problem that
happens is
is that number's gonna come down it'll
naturally come down to probably 2.5 or
whatever
and so what you're going to be looking
for is come july
august you're going to be looking for
that number is it
trending back up that's when the problem
happens
so when we get rid of those base effects
from comparing the last year
we actually get to normal numbers again
if we start seeing
that inflation trend go up and all of a
sudden it's like oh man
we had more inflation in july we had
more inflation in august we had more
inflation in september
it's trending up then you know the fed's
going to start going
uh-oh that's not good now all of a
sudden
uh that that whole argument of stable
prices is potentially going to lead the
fed to act sooner
especially if at the same time the
unemployment rate is falling so which
i expect it will uh unemployment runs
out in september so people are going to
be looking for jobs the people who are
unemployment
hopefully people are already looking for
jobs so at the same time as the
unemployment
rate plummets if all of a sudden july
september
august around there we start seeing that
inflation rate trick up as well
fed's going to u-turn and they're going
to end up having to raise rates much
sooner than expected and we'll probably
see that 2022 rate increase
that's when things are going to get
really blurry because they really
screwed up in 2018 when they tried to do
this
uh graham i think we were actually we
were at some something in um
oh gosh where was it it was like beverly
or not beverly i don't know maybe it's
holly
west hollywood or something like that
the driven the driven conference oh
gosh yeah so that that morning
i actually did a live stream uh
prepping uh on my phone i was sitting
there like at the registration area i
did a live stream on my phone
hey guys okay look this is what fed
chair jerome powell just said like same
thing i'm still doing today which is
crazy because it's like three years
later
but uh they screwed up you know they
jacked rates up in in may
and that summer they spanked real estate
real estate prices plummeted uh you know
10 15 20
today you did a video on real estate
prices going up 17
they could fall that in in two months if
they jack up rates too fast
they failed in 18 caused a market crash
at the end of 18
that same thing could happen again and
that's my 10 scenario that's gonna suck
got it do you think though it's possible
to have inflation
with somewhat high unemployment
like to the point where possible yeah
like to the point where
you know they want equal employment for
everybody
is it possible that they don't achieve
that
but inflation still comes up and they're
at a crossroads between
what do we do do we go against what we
said we're gonna do or do we just let
inflation happen
or we raise rates and then all of a
sudden everything we said
means nothing yeah could happen
so black unemployment for example right
now is like 9.6
white unemployment is 5.4 percent
and uh it's entirely possible that the
entire unemployment rate
doesn't get down to those lower levels
until like 2023 or something so imagine
we get to the end of 2021
and we we barely get to 5 or you know
what unemployment stays stuck at five
and a half percent for some reason
uh or six percent uh elevated levels
and then all of a sudden we see
inflation because you know the supply
chains are still broken
yeah can that happen totally totally
that could happen and
the that persistent inflation might stay
if all of a sudden people are
are continuing to pay prices and there's
there's
less competitiveness to bring those
prices down
because maybe it's harder to start a
business maybe it's harder to
open another lumber mill maybe it's
harder to open another
uh you know circuit factory or or maybe
it takes two years for
for a factory to get up and running to
compete sure could we be in an era of
high inflation for the next two years
yeah that's gonna suck and and that
would be entirely because
all of a sudden maybe there's more
demand than we really have the supply
for despite
everything maybe firing on all cylinders
again no covid but we still need that
many more factories but it takes that
much time to do more factories or create
new factories
yeah yeah sure we could definitely there
is a scenario where we can see higher
inflation for the next few years
do i think it'll be more than like four
percent no way like i i don't see any
scenario where it goes over four percent
but the fed's gonna panic if it sits at
three percent longer than i think these
next two months
you know they're gonna be expecting it
to go to two five bob around that two
five range their measure of inflation
the pce yeah
yeah but it but if it goes up more than
that yeah they'll start panicking i
think
but for now they're just steadfast and
the market's starting to believe them
that's the other thing what's weird is
the market's finally starting to believe
the fed again
and we're starting to see yields come
down the 10-year treasury's coming down
the five years coming they're all
trending down
that's a sign the market's starting to
believe them again couldn't you couldn't
you argue too that inflation would be
good
for some asset prices like wouldn't you
believe
that for real estate yeah great in the
long term
okay very bad in the short term so uh
because they're going to jack up rates
to combat inflation
which is terrible in the short term for
real estate in the long term if we
actually have real inflation oh come on
yeah like
it's it's it's wonderful it's wonderful
if you own a bunch of debt
uh especially on real estate in fact i
want to go buy more real estate
one the other reason i paid off my
margin i haven't mentioned this but
another reason i paid off my margin is
because i now got six million dollars or
actually no it's like seven
seven or eight million dollars if i
wanted to available in credit lines
to where if i let's say found a deal i
had to put let's say i got together
eight million dollars and i found a deal
i had to put i don't know 35 percent on
divided by 35.
uh i could buy a deal for 23 million
dollars if i wanted to i could go find
some multi-family building by a 23
million
multi-family building now i'd be taking
out that margin again i'd be taking a
big risk
but if i found a big juicy building the
tax write-offs on that
i don't think i'd be paid income taxes
this year now that's a good segue
to what's going on right now with the uh
the capital gains
that would be a huge win for real estate
i gotta say
i would be tempted if if capital gains
stayed at uh let's just say
40 percent plus it's an additional what
is it 3.8
percent on top of that so we're looking
at uh yeah so let's we'll call it 43
44 i would be very tempted at that point
to stop investing in the stock market
and actually get back into real estate
i'd be
very tempted so funny you say that i
could not agree more
uh in fact just the last few days i've
been looking at real estate every day
probably 10x what i had been uh quite
frankly i uh
look in may i went ham buying real
estate last year
i'm very happy i did i bought 11
properties last year it was insane
too much at once happy i did but
once i got overwhelmed in august with
all the projects i was doing
in real estate i'm like that's it i'm
done
i don't think i've looked at redfin as
much between
august and uh probably
what april yeah august to april so what
is that i don't know like eight months
or something like that
i've probably looked at redfin and
zillow and realtor.com
more in the last two days than i have in
the last eight months
right you know a big thing for me that i
was actually thinking
lately i've been doing a lot of
investing in startup companies
and the advantage for me there is that i
could lock in my basis right now
and that my hope was that four to ten
years from now who knows when
i would be able to cash out this very
large amount and utilize the long-term
capital gains
but if i have a choice between taking my
money now and having access to it today
then being taxed almost 50 percent 10
years from now
i would almost rather say it's not worth
it anymore
it's better to have the access to the
cash now go and buy real estate
and take a risk tying up my money for
five to ten years
that's huge and i think that's going to
be a big deterrent
for a lot of investors a lot of startup
companies if that happens
do you want to explain exactly what the
new proposal says
because your integrity is off right sure
so
they're actually call they're calling it
the death of
a potentially silicon valley so uh
because of exactly what you've described
because think about it venture
capitalists in silicon valley
they're they're trying to do exactly
we're talking about they find small
startups
and hey let's invest you know uh a
million dollars 10 million dollars
50 000 whatever any range depending on
if somebody's an angel investor or vc
uh and uh they're they're looking to
cash out
the point of doing these startup
investments is to cash out at some point
and you can't exchange that which is
just a tax way of saying
when you cash out you pay taxes so
the the old school mo was
angel invest in the robin hoods the
facebook the coinbase whatever when
they're tiny
then motivate them to ipo when the
market seems ripe
go ipo or direct list whatever
and what it does is it lets all of those
original investors
out it lets them all out and those are
some sweet
long-term gains taxed at 20 for
you know if you're making over like 500
something thousand dollars it's taxed at
20
plus your state uh if you're making less
than that it's taxed at like 15
if you're making less than 40 grand
capital gains or taxed zero percent
ish i'm rounding on those numbers right
around there
the uh the new proposal how do we get
back here
this is weird i don't know i'm still on
public though public i thought we're in
private
i thought we're in private no jack
you're just dumb
oh i guess i am dumb for not getting my
free stock worth up to 50
on public you haven't done that yet i
haven't oh my
it takes you just a few minutes to do
and the stock is worth all the way up to
fifty dollars
fifty dollars yes fifty dollars and i
also heard there's actually an event
going on if you deposit a hundred
dollars by may 7. yeah you could get a
completely free stock worth of tesla
tesla tesla elon musk
and that's almost 700 right now yes
assuming the current market price as of
today
well graham how can i sign up you don't
remember i just told you like a minute
ago yes you could use the link down
below in the description it's totally
easy to do and they don't route your
order flow
oh my i will do that right now thank you
and we should get back to the video what
happened to kevin we left them hanging
back to you kevin back to you kevin
says that okay as soon as you make over
a million dollars
of income all of your capital gains
doesn't matter if it's a dollar or if
it's a million dollars or 10 million
every capital gain that you make once
you make over a million dollars
is a tax that ordinary income levels
which uh biden expects to raise to 39.6
percent
add to that the obamacare investment tax
which adds 4.8
now you're at 43 point was at 43.4
percent
in taxes add to that your state tax
uh you guys are in vegas y'all lucky
okay 43 point
what did i say here 39.6 plus the 4.8
that's uh i don't know somewhere around
like the 44ish level
uh plus california 13.4
i'm paying 57-ish percent in taxes
that's insane
so now this is why they're talking about
the death of potentially vcs in silicon
valley
uh and the death of silicon valley it's
gonna it's gonna end up being texas
like people are gonna start doing this
in austin texas more florida more miami
it's gonna be miami and texas are gonna
be the new
hubs maybe seattle probably not seattle
austin and miami probably
buy real estate there that would be a
good idea by releasing vegas
yeah you guys got to get vcs in vegas i
mean you got the conventional centers
so uh i mean now think about it
if you're in california you're you're
giving almost 60
of of your long-term gains
uh to the government if you're a venture
capitalist like why why bother
so that begs the question okay well
let's say let's just come up with an
example
if i had and this has important
implications too for people even making
under a
a million dollars because it affects
them and i'll show you how
if now somebody says okay i'm gonna take
20 million dollars
and instead of putting it into a vc fund
which raises valuations of companies
which
helps raise ipo prices and helps raise
stocks
it all trickles up uh those stocks those
valuations go higher
they ipo higher people cash out they
have more money to go buy other stocks
it's all part of the big game so now
instead of maybe the vcs
putting that 20 million dollars in to i
don't know
startup you know the next makeup startup
or tech startup or whatever
they take that 20 mil and go i'm gonna
go buy a 100 unit apartment building
somewhere
then they take like a 30 cost
segregation write-off
they instead of in the future paying
60 on their long-term gains they go
today
i'm gonna save eight million dollars in
taxes while i'm investing in this
because i cost segregated it
especially if they they call themselves
a real estate professional which i think
a lot more people are going to become
real estate professionals after this
mess
but then they go in the future 10 years
down the road i want to sell this
building
just 10 31 exchange it aka don't pay
taxes
because you're just gonna put those in
the next building do it forever and in
the future when you die
pass it on to your children tax-free
right well isn't the world i mean then
you have the estate
tax which then you start getting into
taxes then you'll then you'll set up a
trust
yeah then you start having to do some
funny things
but uh slowly divesting your portfolio
but that's that's
problems like if you're a couple that
those are problems when your assets are
over you know
your net worth's over like 23 million
dollars right
at that point you got other problems but
yeah i am worried that uh i'm
legitimately concerned that if that does
pass a lot of investors and even
entrepreneurs would say what's the point
if i sacrifice
everything to start up a business i'm
gonna work away at it
not making any money let's say for five
years with the hope of
maybe one day it's gonna pay off
they'll think you know what's the point
if i have to give sixty percent of that
away
i'm not even gonna bother why do that
for forty percent of the upside
when i could risk a hundred percent of
the downside
oh yeah i i mean it's it's a calculation
i mean
it's i think the entrepreneurial spirit
will still be there there's still going
to be people who are like look i'm
broken in a basement i got an idea
look i you know maybe i'm making 10
grand working at red robin
you know going from 10 grand to 100
grand income is going to be huge for
them so i think the entrepreneurial
spirit will still be there
but at what point does it become limited
and i think that's that's where what
you're saying is so right because
at what point do venture capitalists
just say you know what
i don't want to invest anymore i don't
want to do vc anymore because what's the
point
why why i'm giving away so much money i
think that's where the issue comes is
the funding for those entrepreneurs is
is going to be less
and uh future valuations will be lower
it all it all balances out like they say
there's no free lunch
but i remember 2015
i did the most deals i ever did in a
year it was like 61 deals or something
like that
by myself without an assistant that was
the most stressed i've ever had in my
life and it was so
toxic it was bad and i remember
sitting with my father-in-law for beer
i'm like i just worked
so hard to have the biggest year of my
life in real estate
which was i don't know like probably
somewhere around 600 grand in
commissions or something like that
which is really freaking amazing and the
expenses are so low in real estate i
probably had like 50 grand of expenses
so here you go worked so hard to make
550k
built this business up for five years
and now it's this is awesome this is so
cool
and then i look and go oh my gosh every
extra 100 grand i'm making i'm giving
like
47 or whatever to the you know the
federal government the state of
california or more i think it was like
50
at the time why am i doing this like
what's the point
and in 2016 i consciously
decided i'm going to work less and
instead of making 600 grand being
stressed
out like crazy because i was so
disillusioned with how much i was paying
taxes i'm like
i'm just going to take it easier i'm
just going to have fun like why why am i
working so hard to give so much to the
government
and i i still did well i had a 400
000 year you know after expenses be like
350
but it was way less stressful and 110
taxes had the influence in that wow
that's wild so what do you think the
chances are of this passing
what i think is going to happen is that
he's going to ask a lot
they're going to ask for more than they
know they can get and i think it's a
negotiation tactic
and they're going to start at 40 percent
and then work their way
maybe find a middle ground interestingly
enough though i i did research on this a
while ago this is a few months ago and i
found a an
article uh that actually dove
into this further and actually studied
this and they found that the optimal
uh long-term capital gains tax was 28 in
terms of
encouraging people actually follow it
not so much as to hold their investments
not sell but they found that that was
the ideal amount
28 to encourage people to still invest
but while maximizing tax revenue
that's interesting uh yeah so uh
well a couple things there um
do we think that uh biden well so first
of all
i don't think we're gonna see dc
statehood dc statehood
it would give democrats pretty much
complete control they
you know they they would have sway
over uh the moderate democrats who
potentially hold things up in this
situation but i don't think that's going
to happen
because then joe manchin would lose a
lot of his power so right now
because that's the dc statehood's not
going to get through the senate
republicans aren't going to go for that
you're not going to see that as budget
recon
so pass the house but it's not going to
pass the senate
the that leaves people like joe manchin
uh standing in the way of what biden
wants biden i think you're right
wants to start high and come across as
negotiating
but ultimately as long as he gets his
democrats on board
he doesn't need a single republican he
doesn't need to negotiate
all he has to do is convince joe manchin
so far the only thing
he's joe manchin has complained about
has been the corporate tax rate
he says i don't want to see corporate
tax rates higher than 25
he hasn't said anything about the
uh capital gains tax you know taxing it
and
the way the biden administration is
branding this is hey look
it only affects one third of one percent
of people
they're right it does only affect the
top one third of the top one percent
now we happen to be in that so it sucks
but uh but yeah that's the way they're
branding it so
unless you get somebody like a moderate
like joe manchin coming out going no you
know this is ridiculous
joe manchin could end up going look give
me the give me the 24
give me a 23 give me a 25 corporate tax
rate
and i'll give you your vote on the
long-term cap gains for the rich folk
uh yeah i think it could pass i would
probably say i'm 50 50 on it right now
wow that's actually higher i was
thinking realistically there's
there would be no way for this to pass
as is i was i would expect
maybe not 39 or maybe they do a tiered
system
i've seen a few different proposals from
just random people online
that i actually really agree with a few
of them uh
break up long-term capital gains in
terms of how long you've held your
investment
maybe it's if you've held it uh between
year one and year two
you get taxed as ordinary income maybe
your three goes down from 39 to 35.
you're four
thirty five to thirty and maybe a year
eight
then it's full-on long-term capital
gains to really encourage long-term
investment of longer than a year
uh or have uh have it structured in such
a way where maybe
your first million dollars would be
taxed at you know 25 percent the next
million dollars would be taxed
you know and have that be a threshold
just like any other
i think it'd be very massive bump
uh and it's so sense i think that's uh i
think those are great ideas
uh i think they're they're possible uh
yeah i think uh
to to see any of those sort of take hold
you gotta watch those moderates because
it's it's not the republicans have so
little power right now
it's amazing just how little they
actually have
uh and i like those ideas and
i think sure is is some a tiered system
like that possible
yeah but look you know i mean look back
to what we have in history here
and and it's it's been recent but i look
back at the stimulus package
joe biden says look we're gonna do the
extra fourteen hundred dollars
and we're gonna do uh the um he
initially came out and said four hundred
dollars was the plan
through the end of september and so what
they did was
they took the 400 made it 300 that was a
compromise
instead of going through the end of
september it actually only goes through
the end of august
so first week of september-ish and they
cut the eligibility for the 1400
stimulus check uh a good chunk like a
couple making 200k
wasn't getting it isn't getting it at
all anymore now at the cutoff's 160
instead of 200k
so i do think there could be fine-tuning
like that but the bigger pieces
they still got still got the 1400 still
got unemployment through basically
september
uh but yeah it is 100 less so is it
possible we'll see some adjusting like
that
and and will it come with maybe some
tears sure but i think it probably
be a small adjustment i don't think it's
going to be a really big adjustment like
biden scott
he's got a lot of power right now if
he's got to give a few little
concessions away to get get some
moderates on board that he needs to get
to his 50 votes
that's what it'll give but i don't think
it's going to be a big adjustment
if you were to offer a solution to long
long term capital gains
what do you think is the most effective
and reasonable rate that it should be
taxed at
i mean i i haven't done the research on
that you know
graham mentioned uh that he had and i
thought that's great i mean personally i
i
i like uh you know if they're trying to
pay for infrastructure which is what
they're trying to do
i would rather see them focus on on use
taxes
right i mean like tax i don't know i
don't understand
why they're not taxing carbon emissions
i mean this has been this has been
studied so many times the world bank
talks about it the imf talked about it
this morning they were talking about
taxing carbon emissions and how right
now the world's only valuing
i don't know exactly the number but it
was like right now the world's only
valuing carbon emissions at like
two dollars per i think it's metric ton
i don't know exactly what it was
something like that
uh and they're like really if we want to
have a green revolution we need to start
valuing carbon emissions at like 70 a
metric ton
and uh and you know that's that's i
think the direction you go
you want to raise money tax the
polluters
uh not like what
you know taxing and potentially robbing
a venture capital of startup investments
through these higher tax rates i don't
i'm not
heavily in support of that i'm also not
heavily in support of a higher
individual tax rate going from where we
are now what the 38 percent back to the
39.6
because i personally felt that dis
incentivization that's another word
uh so you know where what's the right
answer i mean to me
which they're not gonna do i think the
right answer is is where they're not
looking it's and it's taxing carbon
emissions to pay
for their infrastructure but they're not
even remotely interested in that
so it's going to end up being something
with capital gains and something with
the ordinary taxes going up
uh i j you know what i am grateful for
so far
is no mention and you know what if this
is where we stop
and it's it's no more no more of these
tax changes
i'm actually going to knock on wood
maybe just seal my lips over here
why are we here again i don't know man
this is weird we shouldn't be back here
then why are we here it's probably
because you didn't get your free stock
worth all the way up to fifty dollars
oh i'll do that right now you haven't
done it yet okay i'll do it right now it
takes you just a few moments to do and
you could get a free stock worth
all the way up to fifty dollars with a
chance shh bailey
bailey with a chance to get a completely
free stock of tesla when you deposit 100
by may 7. wow so i can get a chance to
win a free stock of tesla that's it and
it just takes you a few minutes
i'll get on it right now all right let's
get back to the video and hopefully we
don't end up back here again
because they have not talked about or
they have not brought up again
because they've previously talked one
1031 exchange getting eliminated oh yeah
and the stepped up tax base is getting
eliminated both of those
are big because see my escape from this
this new rule
is just going into real estate well the
steps of tax basis was
uh implemented uh or overturned in
california though
well well so there i think i think then
they're uh they're
two different stepped up tax bases than
we're touching on so there's the
property tax
basis which you're totally right on that
that's that's gone that's what i mean
property tax
yeah so the property tax basis you're
right that's gone and they snuck that in
there
i wouldn't be surprised that that comes
up on a ballot again in california
california is a mess right now with all
the proposals and nonsense they've got
uh the basis which really doesn't affect
us the stepped up the other stepped up
tax bases
the other stepped up tax basis is you
die and
let's say you have a you know place you
bought for
400 000 you depreciated it to zero
and now it's worth 10 million dollars
just be extreme if i
sold it the day before i died on my
deathbed
i would have to pay capital gains taxes
on 10 million dollars
right after selling fees right if i die
my heirs would pay zero taxes
because they would move that basis from
zero to ten mil
and all of a sudden uh they could sell
it the very next day after i die
and pay zero dollars in taxes okay which
is just crazy
so that's that's what i was mentioning
so what i was referring to is property
tax
yup yeah exactly so so that's where
real estate is still this like uh
and you're right california they sneak
things in i mean that's messed up they
got rid of that basis adjustment
but real estate still has this
this beautiful holdout right now that uh
even though prices are high
i'm really tempted to to double down and
buy some more real estate
especially if i can get my hands on a
bigger building or even some more single
families i'm in escrow
and a single family fixer-upper right
now uh and uh i just want more of them
i don't even want the cash flow i don't
care about the cash flow i just want to
control
the value because it's also if i'm wrong
on those
options the real estate is actually
going to be a hedge because if i'm wrong
on the options that means we have
inflation
which should be good for my real estate
and my real estate debt long term
do you think they would ever touch the
laws regarding real estate or tax code
regarding real estate
to make it just as as as bad as as
investing in like stocks and stuff no
because the politicians they all got
real estate
they're they're not gonna pick up where
they sleep so that's what it is the
problem with real estate yeah that i
feel like you don't have
as much with stocks which sounds crazy
but real estate is the fifth
largest lobby it's one of the top five
lobbies i think national rifles too
yeah national realtor association is up
there in like top five
the nra sees this stuff about stepped-up
tax basis
uh and and uh you know 1031 exchange as
soon as they see that
the national association of realtors if
i said adhesive
uh national association realtors they
get in there and i wouldn't i would not
be shocked
you start having the the lobbyists
showing up in congress like
hey wrote up an idea for you folks on
biden's team
here you go check this out oh
doubling the capital gains taxes on
people making over a million dollars
yeah yeah it's a really great oh okay
yeah we'll bring this over to biden
and says nothing about real estate i
wouldn't be surprised if you got a ton
of people in the real estate lobby doing
that stuff
they don't want anything about real
estate mention and guess what
whether that's what's happening or not
real estate's not getting mentioned
knock on wood
i wanted to circle back to the options
just to know like what kind of
investments you made in those
in those contracts what kind of
investments i made
uh yeah like what stocks expiration date
strikes and stuff like that yeah just
like
generally speaking obviously not every
single one but the bigger positions
i'll give you some examples here so i
did this on tuesday which tuesday was a
crap
day like tuesday was bad everything was
in the toilet
and i'm like man if i make a transition
into options and i leverage in more
probably a good time to do it when
everybody's freaking out
uh i love i love uh taking advantage of
freakouts
so um a lot of them went into tesla yeah
a lot
uh actually this is a better spreadsheet
uh no this is easier
yeah so i've got i spread them out on
tesla
i got 650 900 1300
1725 and 900
calls all pretty much jan in march 2023
so they're pretty long
and some in the money most of them out
of money
but then again the ones that are in the
money i put let's see hold on let me see
here the 650s
uh 320 grand into the 650s 458 grand
into the 900s
a hundred grand into the 1725 like
that's like the yolo
uh 900 one has you know 353 000. so lots
of tesla
of course it's my highest conviction i
still believe it people think i'm stupid
and crazy for doing but
i don't care i love tesla it's bad
but i also threw a couple hundred grand
at sea
couple 150 grand in a lemonade 125 into
neo these are all all pretty much 20
23's
uh you know some money into some of the
specs like matterport or cciv
end face end phase i put i like it
540 000 into
end phase options for january
uh 20 2023
150 so i bought them slightly in the
money i think they were like 155 at that
point i think they ended at like 170
today the the share price
and right now those options alone are up
129 000 they're up 31
it's like those end phase ones are just
printing money right now uh
coinbase down like 17 grand and
most of the options that i got on to
actually
with the exception of coinbase every
option that i got on tuesday is up
so i mean that's it's very short term
recording this on friday
so taxes how do taxes work on options
when you exercise those options
yeah so i'm not going to exercise them
i'm going to sell these uh the two
things i can do i can exercise them but
if i exercise them i lose the extra
value
because if i exercise i'm going to take
the shares exercising is actually a
great way
to save taxes though because let's say i
have this
650 call on tesla and then
in january of 2023 uh
tesla's at two thousand and then i
exercise
and i get the shares for six fifty hey
that's great i buy the shares for 650
the market value is two thousand dollars
right now perfect i'm up
but i plan on uh oh and at that point in
that scenario
i wouldn't pay taxes that would be built
into my cost basis of those shares
because i'd just be getting them for
650. okay
great plus whatever i paid for the
contract but
with options a good chunk of the value
is hope i call it hopium just to make it
simple uh and hopium is like
well put it it could go up even more
you know and uh i wanna i wanna profit
off not only what it's in the money but
off the hopium
so i want that opium so i'll probably
sell these
well next time we get a big rally i'll
sell them if we get a big rally next
month i'll dump all of these options and
i'll just buy shares again because i
just don't want the stress
but uh whether i sell them
you know this year or next year whatever
when i sell those contracts
they'll just be capital gains either
short term or long term depending on on
when that rally comes and when i sell
them
so i will be looking at how good of a
rally it is in terms of how much i'm up
considering that i have to pay taxes how
much am i net up
and then does it make sense to take that
net treasure chest and
throw it all into shares and my goal is
to be
better off than where i was before
except have no margin
that makes sense it's a crazy yolo no
it's smart a lot of the in the money
stuff i'm totally on board with like the
leaps and stuff with the in the money
calls i love those
that's like if i do do any like um long
calls that's typically what i do
and i bought tuesday as well which was
pretty awesome
but uh but yeah i totally i i agree with
that i think that was smart to to get
into some options like that
yeah it's i will say though graham
you've got this style of i just don't
want stress and i
i admire that because look i mean you
know now i got to keep an eye out for
that rally
if i had the shares i i wouldn't have to
you know
yeah but keeping an eye on making a
whole bunch of money that's not a
problem
that's not stressed your stress is i
gotta keep it on the market so when i
make too much money
i i lock in this profit yeah
i mean it could all go down too but but
yes yes
the the theory is that is what i'm
waiting for
gosh what do you what do you think of
jack holding on to dogecoin
what do you think of that he he turned
his 100
investment into it was 9 000 like a
couple of days ago a hundred dollars to
nine thousand dollars can't believe that
and yeah and had a and had i held my
thousand dollars would have turned into
like 91 000
at the peak i i mean i put 25 grand into
doge
uh and it turned into 75 grand and i
sold it so fast because i'm like dude i
made 50 grand
in a day see ya you know
i had same thing had i held i don't even
want to do the math on that because i
would feel
when did you sell did you sell when i
hit like 10 cents
um i sold this was actually a while ago
i think this was back in january
like mid-january wow so it would have
been
back then like five cents six cents uh
your order to buy one million doge has
been filled for twenty five thousand
dollars
it was one million doge so what is that
so a million
so four hundred four hundred and
ten thousand is that what it is no yeah
that's what it is
that's the value 25 cents right so times
twenty five so it would have been two
hundred
two fifty so at this peak it was like
four ten yeah
gosh hey you still did better than
someone that i know better than me oh
yeah you you made money with doge i i
i cannot say i've done that before to
turn 109 000
is incredible why not you told me to
sell when it was at 6 thousand
you said sell right now and then guess
what happened it went down but then it
went back up to nine thousand
right but then you would still be up
fifteen hundred dollars where you are
today but it's not about
it's not about the quick profit it's
about a the principle and it's about be
sticking with profit it's been holding
on to this for a year all right it's
been marinating but like it's about
it's about the principle at which you
inve like why you invested on
like in an investment kevin the grounds
at which you you invested in which which
for me
was like i think it's funny that there's
dogecoin
i think it's cool it's unique and that's
why i put it in and i knew for a fact i
was holding on for life
for life for life so you're gonna hold
this until you're 50 60 years old
i knew look that hundred dollars i was
like this is play money this is fun
money and i've had so much fun with it
i've had so much fun and just because i
made nine thousand dollars you know i
get a comment every here and
every like every now and then some
somebody's like patting my back on the
podcast
or whatever they'll be like good job
jack you're diamond hansing you know
look at graham he sold out
you know that the night of that he
bought it or whatever and those comments
like that make me proud to hold on to
dogecoin
even if sure i'm down five thousand
dollars or four thousand dollars since
its peak but
but whatever that was a burn that was a
burn yeah
look wow it depends on how you look at
it
yeah if you are a hodler
then good for you then then the
fluctuations are entertainment
they're fun there's something to talk
about wow look what doge did today
you're a hodler great if you're when i
say
if you're a trader fine do the
fluctuations you're a hodler
great hotel forever fine i'll probably
hold tesla for
forever i don't know maybe maybe
something will change in 20 years who
knows but that's the plan right now it's
just a total
uh i don't care what happens in the
short term maybe that's the same thing
with you on doge
so uh that way when kevin o'leary tells
me oh
you know what if tesla goes down forty
percent like well buy
more you know it doesn't matter but
uh i think there is uh a person that uh
invested in doge and they put all their
money in it because they see elon musk
tweeting about it
they put you know their their only
hundred thousand dollars in
and uh it turns into a million dollars
and
then they're like there's actually i'm
pretty sure oh there was a there was a
cnbc article about this
this guy put 140 grand in it turned into
over a million dollars at one point wow
and uh so he literally became a dogecoin
millionaire and i'm thinking myself and
we don't know but let's say the dude
works making 50 grand a year
i'm like i'm reading this i'm like this
is incredible dude like
oh my gosh sell like change your life
this is this is
life-changing amounts of money for you i
don't know how much you make but
assuming it's like the average you know
50 60k or whatever
sell what are you doing you just you got
like 10 you know
after taxes you got 10 years after taxes
you got 10 years worth of working your
job
boom in two months what are you doing
and in the article they're like well my
plan is to hold on until it hits 10
million
and then i'll sell 1 million and live
off that and like
okay look at some point it is fine it is
i'm happy that you're bullish on a
momentum trade
but i'm not bullish on it i just want to
make i just want to make it clear i'm
not bullish
i'm not bullish on dogecoin she'll make
that clear to anyone who's
watching so jack we're back here again
oh no why is that because you didn't get
your free stock worth all the way up to
50 dollars but i actually did this time
i actually did check this out no way
really
whoa i know congratulations thank you
i'm so happy wow did you pause it a
hundred dollars too yes i did okay so
now you're gonna be entered for a chance
to win a free stock of tesla
of what tesla oh my gosh whoa okay let's
get back to kevin now back to you kev
if it's a momentum trade and you got
life-changing amounts of money
gtfo nine thousand dollars isn't going
to change your life jack
fifteen hundred dollars a day that nine
thousand dollars somebody could hack
your robin hood tomorrow and take your
dogecoin away and it would make a
difference to your life
this dude assuming he's working for 50
60k
who turned ocean to a million dollars
and and he's like oh
this is the best thing ever it's the
best thing sliced bread it's gonna 10x
really it's gonna go from from a 50
billion dollar market cap
to a 500 billion dollar market cap
doubling what ethereum is right now
folks
like at some point and maybe it'll
happen but at some point some logic has
to set in that's all i got to say
so you met with kevin o'leary how did
that come about
instagram no did you did you message him
no they're uh uh well actually no i had
messaged him a while ago but he didn't
answer
uh uh so but what happened was
uh his like media coordinator or
whatever was like
oh i saw you on youtube and uh i
i have these people who would be
interesting for you to interview or
whatever
uh so i went into uh kevin o'leary's dms
and you had already messaged us so like
she was coming to message me but my
message was in there and she's like oh
this is perfect
so it's cut a little bit of both cool
and what was that like to meet him
to me it was so real yeah
a little bit uh it's probably
i have to say i haven't been nervous for
for an interview
uh the only time i was ever nervous was
was the robin hood one
and i think it was because i was worried
that everybody was gonna
hate the fact that i interviewed the ceo
so i was really worried about backlash
so i was like sweating bullets like
you know the pit stains and everything
i'm like oh crap this could be really
bad
you know another one i was really
nervous for actually was i did this
interview with uh
lauren southern like really really
politically remember
yes yeah that was that has like a
77 like ratio like the worst ever
uh in a very very long period of time
that i was nervous about
very very nervous uh so i think the
nerves come from like
okay is this gonna be good or bad for
the channel if it's potentially bad i'm
freaking out
i'm thinking about it from the channel
point of view for kevin o'leary it was
really natural because i we just get
into
talking uh it was um
you know i i think it was it was
interesting uh when
when you know they sort of first pop in
kind of like the zoom call and it's like
oh damn there he's actually there you
know like he's a real he's a real person
like that that initial feeling was
certainly there uh but yeah i mean um
i mean it's fun it's all i could say i
look forward to doing more things like
that
i'd love to get like politicians on like
how cool if i if we could get like uh
mitch mcconnell or nancy
like is there gonna be a voice stimulus
fancy
they gotta start doing that imagine
mitch mcconnell just streaming with
pokemane
or something they gotta start to
seriously you know you know
one of these days when like people our
age are becoming politicians and they're
really getting involved because everyone
right now
is like 50 60 70 years old imagine now
when when we're in our you know 50s or
60s
doing like you know tick tock dances and
stuff like that for votes
like imagine nancy pelosi on tick tock
doing
[Laughter]
do i want to imagine her doing that
and then at the end it's like vote for
me race
caitlyn jenner's running for governor
oh yes yeah yeah yeah that
so we start getting more of the uh
social media incidents
involved in politics guaranteed that's
coming
that's right that's where i think it's
going because guaranteed if the rock
runs for president
guaranteed he would have a solid chance
the rock the rock
why him because he's likable let's say
one bad thing about the rock
i don't want you to you i don't want to
try it try trying to try to
one critique besides i did not like the
movie uh that earthquake movie
i did not like it that's the only bad
thing i have to say about the rock
he's a likeable guy he is yeah he's and
he's with their daughter
or his daughter pause it what about huh
the the earthquake movie with uh his
daughter
yeah yeah what was that what was it
called earthquake
i forget it's like some apocalypse movie
i didn't like that movie
but san andreas yeah that's it san
andreas
it's just not that it wasn't wasn't his
best work
but overall everyone likes him
everyone likes i would it's just a
friendly guy and you would think that if
he's if
it like for international relations and
and just
any anything he says i feel like just
people would just like the guy
income's been plummeting has it been
yeah man april's been rough like uh i
don't know
april's just uh i don't know if it's the
markets or what but like views are
softer
there's less uh uh
less less there's really less stuff
going on you know there was so much i
feel like there's so much more
drama uh over this last year throughout
the pandemic
it was much more uh there was much more
to talk about now i'm i'm
like man i'm going to have to start
going back to new burst pro real estate
videos and i've got like 20 000 views
man
yeah i've noticed i think it's just less
interest overall in the markets
i think people are normalized to it i
think they're getting out of the house
now they're not paying attention as much
as they are and
when there's not something new happening
like every single day
i feel like they're just losing interest
uh but i think i still think obviously
there's gonna be that core audience that
loves anything to do with the markets
but it's certainly not like it
i think will be or or has been over the
last year
so i've never seen it doesn't help the
market's been trending
down you know when the market's trending
down i feel like you get people that
uh lose faith in the markets especially
folks who are
you know look there are a lot of people
who got absolutely
burned on gamestop there are a lot of
people who got
burned on amc there are a lot of the
moment
i mean they're going to be a lot of
people who are burned on on dogecoin or
safe moon or whatever right
they're going to be all a lot of these
really high hype things that are going
to burn a lot of people
and uh or even the yolo options
it's not a good thing that wall street
bets
shows oh look at my yolo bet here that
turned into all this money and it was
like a two-week call option or something
crazy you know
that's not good because it uh it really
i think people try it they're like well
i want my yolo too
and uh when that falls apart they've
gone in too
deep and then that's it the markets are
rigged
and they never come back that's bad uh
you know people already think the
markets are rigged enough i personally
i think i i in the minority on that i
think uh
i think there are certainly consortiums
of things that go on like when the
hedges all decide to short spax together
i'm sure there's there's that level of
riggedness
but uh ultimately it just it comes down
to the push and pull of everybody trying
to make a buck out there
and i think if you if you can be in your
long stock positions you can make lots
of money in the stock market
but a lot of people are going to get
burned out of it i don't know what do
you guys think
i don't know i think from an attention
standpoint
i would just say that there's been a big
focus on investing a big focus on the
market i think this has been
the talk for really the last year and i
think as we progress out of that people
are just
they're going to get bored and i think
when they see the market trading
sideways or they
they don't see these 20 percent gains
every month
what's the point let me go focus on
something else and maybe that will be a
self
a self-fulfilling prophecy where enough
people get
bored of it and that costs his stocks
not to do as well in the first place and
then even more people get bored of it
but i think again like you said long
term it's not going to make a huge
difference
and uh and in terms of youtube i feel
like it's it's really just
the algorithm will push whatever the or
wherever the attention is
and when the attention is on investing
the algorithm is less likely to push it
so that's what i think we're seeing i
wonder if it could be due to the fact
that like we've seen a slower
or like a little bit of a recovery since
that last huge crash that we had not
huge but like the big crash i don't know
what was that like two months ago or
whatever
i think like that crash because i
remember your viewership was up like
crazy oh yeah like during all of that
and that was around the same time as
gamestop yeah it was like the game
really exciting right and then after the
crash obviously like it it kind of
stayed pretty low for a while
and now since we're making a little bit
of a recovery back that's just not
nearly as exciting as like either
continuing on the trajectory we were at
before the crash
or the crash itself you know like the
recovery getting back to where we were
is just like terrible
but beforehand when we were shooting up
that was i
uh generally when the market is down
viewership is up
overall when the market's doing
fantastic i've noticed fewer people
are are interested in it like no it's
funny no one cares
the market's up ten percent whoa
that'll be one-fourth of views as the
market went down 10
here's what just happened oh for sure oh
for sure 100
i mean march was uh probably
one of the best months ever that that i
had
uh just from like all income streams
combined and views
uh views weren't actually as high as
they were in december but the
march was a really good month in terms
of that but it was
also a terrible month uh in terms of the
market
like the market was just on fire and
there was so much drama coming out of
february like you're talking about we're
coming out of the
the uh you know the um what's it called
the game stop
momentum trades and uh yeah march was
really really incredible and so now it
it kind of feels like we
it's like we're going to the moon in
january feb now
you know end of feb march comes and it
was just like a rocket ship going to the
ground
in certain sectors like you know tesla
went to like 5
30 for a moment you know for a hot
minute i mean like this was a rocket
ship going to the ground
people like no don't buy don't buy
you're going to catch a falling knife
meanwhile i'm buying the whole time i'm
like yep i'll take some 590s i'll take
some 530 i'll take some 610s like
whatever i don't care i'll buy them at
700 whatever i'll buy
uh and uh this rocket ship's going
straight to the ground
that rocket ship going to the ground was
was i mean
terrible for the market great for
business uh
and now it kind of feels like the rocket
was falling out of the sky a little bit
now we're we're doing this kind of like
you know it's kind of like we're
bouncing around right uh
and uh it's it's it's not as engaging
like
it's not uh it's not fun to see the
market go up
uh you know oh it just went up 15 oh it
just went down seventeen percent oh it
just went up six years
like it's that's what it has been
feeling like this consolidation
window that we've been in these last
four weeks it's been exhausting
not engaging it's uh it's
unique too to you where you're kind of
hedged either way in terms of your own
income
because if the market goes down you make
the money back from youtube
the market goes up you might make less
on youtube but you'll make way more from
your investments
i never thought about it that way but
yeah probably probably true
how are you planning to diversify in the
future
because let's just say let's let's just
say youtube cuts in half which i mean
would still be
fantastic but how do you intend to
continue this
yeah um probably uh
i i mean i like what you mentioned
earlier the vlog idea the vlog idea
though
it would have to be it'd have to
incorporate something like if i could
vlog
the family in real estate great i would
love to do that
uh especially if it involved traveling
like say i took advantage of that that
texas and florida thing
it's like all right we're flying down to
texas to buy four homes this weekend
like that could be fun you know take the
kids or whatever and screw around to
texas
and and uh go house hunting or whatever
and especially if somebody else was
filming and editing it together
uh because look i i'm not i'm not i
would not edit it
no thank you i i'm so burned out of
editing
i just don't even edit anymore uh
which is great that we have that
opportunity because like we have live
streaming
opportunities or even podcasts or pretty
much like 95 percent
unedited uh and so um
but yeah for diversifying that would be
really fun i would love doing that
and and just getting out again uh
there's always going to be news to cover
but uh it's gonna be less stressful and
i'm actually looking forward to that
because the last year it's literally
been
refresh oh my gosh there's breaking news
record the video as i'm uploading the
video
oh my gosh there's more breaking news
like
the last year has been so insane and
this is why like sometimes they're like
kevin
how do you how do you do like six videos
a day it's like well there's so much
freaking stuff to talk about
but when we get into this this normal
period of time
where it's like okay maybe you have like
really exciting news twice a week
well i don't have to be sitting here all
day anymore i could go do
the vlogs uh and then if something crazy
happens i don't need anything fancy
we could just i mean you know this just
take our phone
i could go live on my phone i can't
believe what jerome powell just said and
be that i doubt i would even lose
viewers doing that
uh just because news doesn't care news
is about information and perspective
so that combined with uh traveling and
real estate
that'd be beautiful that'd be my dream
that's what i think you should do
i think incorporate that maybe maybe
taper off towards the end of the year
do that do the vlog idea then we can
merge vlogs imagine the collabs that we
could do between vlog
channels the family meets kevin
i would the one thing i would do
differently though is i would still be
doing it on this channel
you wouldn't change you wouldn't do a
new channel i just
i i don't want to split my attention you
know i've seen two and look you guys
haven't mastered okay i think you guys
are the exception though
because i've just and maybe it's me
uh and i'm personally just like
identifying this as more frequent than i
think it is but i don't know
but i think most creators and i could be
wrong about this so it's totally
opinionary
but i believe most creators who create
other channels
end up favoring one and there's no look
you guys have a wonderful set schedule
you know you've got the vlog for one day
you've got the podcast for one day
you've got the three in the main channel
and then what you got the three or three
on the other channel
it's so structured it's perfect it's
literally perfect it's beautiful
uh but i think most people who don't
have that rigid
setup end up favoring one channel and
the other one gets neglected
why would i do i don't i don't want to
do that so for me personally
it makes no no difference i'll i you
know i've noticed the same thing i mean
if i
post more the views go up i post less
the views go down it is simple
the issue though is on a main channel
you're going to get a big portion of
your audience not watching a vlog
because they have no interest in it
and that is going to hurt the
performance of your channel so by
starting a new channel
you're going to get those dedicated 100
000 views that they'll watch anything
and that channel will grow so much
faster because of that
maybe and maybe i'm doing something
wrong there i have this belief
that when i post the video youtube
is so smart the algorithm is so smart it
knows
who to show it to and i don't know if
it's just the algorithm learning so
quickly like you know they send out the
notifications and batches so
say they send out the notification to a
thousand people at first
and they're like okay for some reason
way fewer girls are liking this one like
way fewer girls are clicking on this one
and older dudes are clicking on this one
the next notifications might only go to
those older dudes so i have this this
weird suspicion that no matter what i
post
it'll end up going to the right person
like the uh you know
some of the podcasts i do there's
there's literally nothing different in
my opinion between some of the podcasts
but some of the podcasts that have
really
really interesting broad information
they get 200 250 000 views the kevin
o'leary wants like 600 000 views
wow you've got uh some
miscellaneous ceo interviews really
really niche topic
50 000 views and those could be filmed
within a day of each other
so you'd think if there was like some
kind of punishment we wouldn't see
that uh so i don't know if it's just my
channel but i'll throw up a real estate
video
all of a sudden all the comments are
people like oh my gosh thank you finally
a real estate video
maybe because they're watching more real
estate videos and and youtube's like oh
i haven't posted a real estate video
because the people who are really liking
this are also watching other real estate
videos let's send it out
that's just it's a crazy belief i have
well so what are you doing to keep
yourself busy
uh the channel the channel all the
videos
that's it so i should just make more
videos yeah
i'm trying not to focus on anything
other than just making a video that
that's my
only focus right now is just let's get
these nine videos out a week
nine videos nine eight
i thought it's nine eight no so we got
uh the millennial money
that takes us from seven days millennial
money okay
so three on the main channel three in
the second channel one on the podcast
one a millennial money one on this to
family
nine
yeah videos i forgot about that i didn't
know you were counting that yeah
yeah yeah okay nine videos that that's
my only that's my only priority right
now
so and and right now i'm just i i take
it year by year so i'm like i just got
to keep doing this to the end of the
year
that's just that's because because when
i think like five years down the line i
get overwhelmed
with thinking i gotta be nine videos a
week for five years what
um so i just take it and the end of the
year that's that's
the next goal post keep it going until
then then revamp you ever see yourself
ratcheting down
yeah that's why i want to do the vlog
that my dream
one day would be the vlog you know has
uh you know
2 million subscribers it's getting you
know 500 000 views per video and we just
have fun
and the main channel will never go away
that's maybe you know one video a week
or two videos a week or
a video is needed when there's something
really big to talk about or when i
really want to say something
post on there but i think the vlog would
just add a different element to it it
would be fun
then then i could do all the things that
i've wanted to do that i can't
because of the main channel like going
and traveling
go and do that for six months i can't do
that and keep up this this the momentum
right now
so i think with the vlog i could still
make it happen could still post amazing
content
um and get to do all of those things
that i've always wanted to do that i
haven't
because uh my priority has been the
channel
well i mean i have to say i mean i i
echo that i think that is a
that is the dream right there is is i
think people think oh being a youtuber's
dream
i don't know man being stuck in this box
you know for 12 or 13 hours a day
is pretty draining uh so but
if if yeah if you had just think about
like
two or three videographers videographers
filming you and they did all the editing
for you you literally had to do
nothing and it was just a percentage of
the
uh the revenue and the revenue you were
getting funded your vacations
and now because the vacations are your
content those are tax write-offs too
now you may as well just go live it up
frugal graham turns into yacht graham
i don't know no but the i was watching a
tiny house video earlier today that
seemed to me so
fun there was a tiny house that was
built uh on wheels so you could you
could attach it to a trailer
and it's like 24 feet long eight feet
wide this thing looked incredible
i think it'd be so fun maybe we get two
of them so
jack and alex could be in the trailer
behind the main one
or you know what alex could be driving
then
then i don't i don't know where you you
you could baby passenger seats
then we got you know the cat and the dog
and macy and i
and the back trailer and we could be
guys where do you want to go today let's
go to
uh salt lake city let's go let's go to
vegas today
let's go let's drive to florida we could
do we could do disney world
let's go something like that i think
would be that would be so much fun
what why do you want to drive five you
know four days or whatever to florida
when you could just rent a jet
no because i think the driving is going
away
it's it's visiting all the places in
between and i think the adventure on the
way there
is is part of the excitement uh even if
you do like drive something subscriber
stops
right but even the drive from like la to
las vegas along the way i mean if you
drive it all the way fine
but on along the way there are a whole
bunch there's like a ghost town
that's there um a lot of nothing too
oh bowling yeah exactly we kevin and i
went to a bowling
spot uh on the way i think that was
rancho cucamonga
we did that yes but i just think on the
drive
a lot of fun things can happen on the
drive that's true that's true you
because uh
danny d look at danny duncan man yeah
that means the dream yeah right there
yeah because he took
uh his uh he did the road trip across
across the country too i think i don't
know he drove his tesla from florida
to l.a or whatever and they would just
stop in all these random places like oh
it's
that's yeah that's awesome i thought
danny could be anywhere
danny could be in in a room like you and
somehow you would watch 20 minutes of
him
doing something he would find a way to
make wherever he is
a good time yeah that's true because
think of it
he never realized he never relies on
something happening he is
always the one who makes stuff happen
it's all
it's it's like his his world revolves
around
him and his personality and what he's
doing in the moment
so he could always come up with content
because it's just as long as he's
as long as he's breathing i mean he'll
find a way to make it entertaining
it's true i mean i uh i visited him in
florida
and i remember we were at this uh
asian food uh a restaurant uh i don't
know i had some fried rice or whatever
i don't know why this detail matters
anyway but he says um you know what
we need to buy a used van like right now
and it just starts calling to get used
me as like wait why
it's like we're going to crash it we're
going to f it up
that's like where did that idea ever
come from
did he put it in video or is this stuff
that like he just wanted to do on his
own
uh you know he he's just he's done
multiple videos since then of him
crashing cars and putting cars in a tree
and then they did fireworks and then
they shot the fireworks into the tree
that the two days after i left they had
the fire department at is at this like
you know six acre 10 acre or whatever a
lot uh
and and uh they i don't know they caught
something on fire it's just like there
literally is always something going on
so that's what i want to do i'm not
necessarily putting cars in trees
but just maybe just a fun
light-hearted family-friendly just just
a good old vlog
there's a longevity risk because i mean
think about it you know if
uh you know a lot of the vlog channels
they they come and go
with with the subscribers but news you
know jim cramer's still around
i yes i i would agree with that but i
think a lot of it's too new to really
know how
how much longevity there is i think the
vlog channels where they're doing all
the work themselves or they're filming
every day that's right that's where i
see the worry like roman atwood
was doing a video i think it was like
like five videos a week or something
like that did that for like three
four years so i'm sure that could be
taxing
but and or the casey neistat doing it
all himself
but i think the occasional vlog maybe
once a week
i think he'd keep that going for longer
and we'll see just how much longevity
there is
even with news on youtube who's to say
there's not going to be
uh you know a younger meet kevin out
there who
does a little more funny who's a little
you know as a as a bigger beard
who has a higher quality camera who
knows
who knows congratulations kevin let's
let's
make this video have more views in the
first one let's do that more views than
the first time
well um yeah uh okay uh how do we do
that
let's see the um i did in in
uh march uh at least double
uh the highest month revenue i had
before so
maybe there's there's a thumbnail for
you all right what is
what is it two million dollars it's over
it was over two
holy crap wow
where is it coming from gosh like if you
were to divide it
it's it's if literally it's a
combination of everything because uh
when when
there's so much so much drama in the
markets everything does better because
it's like even like life insurance which
i saw you guys were doing life insurance
like even the life insurance what
seriously like it's everything
wow but uh no this month will be like
the opposite
you know this month they'll all negative
two yeah
yeah but no um 600
something like that which is amazing but
yeah but you're not even but you're not
even counting stocks
like if you go income plus stocks god
that's their title man three million
dollars a month
two million two two something two
million two listen
you can't put two point two it's gotta
be one two three four
it's gotta be an even number so and then
the next time hopefully we can grow it
again
oh my gosh let's get it to four oh gosh
like i think this last year was an
anomaly though so i realized that i mean
uh this last year was insane
um you know there are a few months uh
that have been insane
but i i don't know how sustainable well
i think high numbers like that aren't
sustainable
uh but i do think numbers around like
this month are more sustainable
uh which is kind of like from the cnbc
millennial money breakdown congrats
congratulations thanks before we end we
you got to tell everyone to
destroy the like button subscribe
do the usual folks i have got to ask you
one thing we've been together for almost
two hours here maybe even a little bit
over two
hours do me a favor a little button down
there destroy that like button
share the video like the video subscribe
get it done
do it now so with that said you guys
thank you so much for watching i really
appreciate it kevin thank you so much
for coming on today
this has been so much fun i love these
things i'll link to your information
down below in the description
where you can also get a free stock from
public worth all the way up to fifty
dollars you may as well get it
all of our instagrams are down below in
the description also make sure to
subscribe to the stef family
we post one video a week it's one
really good video it's so good that we
we basically pack the best content
in a given week in 12 minutes or less
it's insane so subscribe to that channel
down below you'll be one of the first
subscribers to that channel so
enjoy thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
for it 51st ever so welcome that you're
coffee hour my name is kevin so far the
podcast is made
blank sweet all right here we go